[Music]
I'm kind of done with you telling me
what I can do
captain marvel with a pg-13
my whole life has sort of accumulated at
this moment there's a lot of material
for me to work with within Captain
Marvel to create something that can feel
personal to me like it's mine and that I
have work to do grieving strength that
comes with human emotion and death the
character Bree understands that these
characters are genuine when we hit the
playground
the gangs become serious it's very
surreal to get suited up as gloves are
getting put on and things are getting
zipped up behind me and the idea of that
star in these colors that represents
strong wealth makes me emotional would
you like to know what you really are
she refuses to give up on herself and
she refuses to give up on humanity she's
the most dynamic character that I've had
the chance to play hey everybody its
charlie there's a whole bunch of Marvel
stuff to just drop recently bunch of new
Captain Marvel footage we have to break
down a brand new plot synopsis involving
Captain Marvel from Avengers endgame and
a whole bunch of new Marvel adult
animation TV shows that they just
confirm that they're making so we'll
talk about the Captain Marvel footage
then I'll talk about all the new
Avengers and game stuff then I'll talk
about that new TV shows that they just
confirm we're doing that Amazon giveaway
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave your favorite
Captain Marvel moment on the video so
first big thing this trailer is mostly
just focusing on everybody telling her
she's trash at various points in her
life I think they show a linear
progression of her growing up as a
little girl playing baseball then at the
Air Force Academy as a cadet and then as
Captain Marvel later in the film in at
various points you have the voiceover of
different people just telling her she's
crap he won't be able to do this you're
never gonna be able to fly and then how
she slowly overcomes that and then by
the end of the film what clearly seems
like they're implying her telling off
Jude Law's Yan raga
when she says I'm kind of done with you
telling me what I can't do it seems like
what's going on here like because it
seems there's a wreckage of a spaceship
and it's some sort of final battle with
his character is that it's meant to be a
parallel scene for earlier in the film
where there's a big wreckage that
activates her powers if it wasn't clear
from the earlier trailers he's probably
around for that too and involved in it
in some way either he's the person that
shoots her plane down and that's what
causes the accident that activates her
powers or she's just around for it
because she's fighting some scroll or
something like that it's unclear who
exactly shoots her plane down and how
that accident starts the sequence of
events that leads to her getting powers
but it probably has something to do with
his character so if you remember during
spider-man into the spider-verse
it's sort of the moment where miles
learns the special quote-unquote
technique from the Prowler like he's
trying to teach him how to pick up women
and he says you put your hand on their
shoulder and just say hey they use it
for a couple funny moments later when he
actually tries it on gwen stacy it goes
horribly wrong it's like a really funny
moment but then later at the end of the
film when he becomes
the fully actualized version of Miles
Morales spider-man he uses the
quote/unquote technique in combination
with his stun ability on the kingpin it
becomes this really awesome badass
takedown so we just sounds like Captain
Marvel is gonna have her own version of
that where she takes down Jude Law's
yawn brog character in a big twist on
what happened with him earlier in the
film when she got her powers there's
also a whole bunch of other new footage
that they work into this too because
there's that special feature at with
them talking about the characters
there's more footage of the aerial chase
scene with what looks like that
prototype shield Quinn jet that might be
from later in the film when she and Nick
Fury are headed into orbit to take out
that scroll spaceship in outer space
like remember when she flies out of the
back of the Quinn jet and goes binary
and just punches that other ship right
out of the sky even though I can't stand
the fact that they cropped these videos
for Twitter and Facebook and a lot of
the social media platforms you do see
her bust out of the scroll mind probe
device look at her hands - she's ripped
the metal bindings out of her arms right
out of the frame and you could see her
hands are glowing beneath the metal as
she starts to bludgeon all the nearby
scrolls with them until they just break
off of her hands there's also but
another scene of her in that big common
area on the scroll ship with all the
earth games in it like there's a
foosball table here there's a jukebox
behind her here it's probably just the
scrolls starting to really enjoy human
culture while this big secret invasion
plot is going on there's another
sequence of her going binary in flying
sideways through frame through a bunch
of a bulkheads in the scroll ship this
is probably a reference to hope from the
first Avengers movie so remember when
Hulk Hulk toute for the first time in
the first Avengers movie they put it in
all the trailers because it was such a
badass shot of him running after a black
widow and just tearing through all the
bulkheads like they were tissue paper
this just seems like it's captain
Marvel's version of that where she goes
full binary so she's at full power and
she's just ripping through all the
bulkheads of these spaceships like
they're tissue paper but getting into
avengers endgame stuff so there was a
brand-new synopsis that involves Captain
Marvel they actually mentioned her by
name in this synopsis that appeared on a
theater chains website so we'll assume
that this is real for now because it
does sound fairly plausible this is me
just quoting it it reads things on earth
are looking dismal after the power of
the Infinity stones decimated half of
the population Thanos has taken up the
mantle of ruler
of the universe leaving the Avengers in
ruin the demigod will only expand upon
his rule unless someone manages to stop
him so with no time to mourn their
losses Black Widow
Thor Captain America and Bruce Banner
must remain resilient and rally the
remaining members of Earth's Mightiest
Heroes and call upon the services of
Captain Marvel together they must figure
out a way to bring back their vanquished
allies and defeat the mad Titan or
suffer a hopeless existence the only
part about that synopsis that makes me
pause and wonder like hey wait a minute
is this actually a real synopsis is when
it talks about Thanos becoming ruler of
the universe because there really hasn't
been anything in his MCU story up to
this point going all the way back to his
first appearance in that first Avengers
film post-credits scene that implies
that he ever really cared about
actually ruling in controlling the
universe now he did one erase half of
all life but that's because he felt like
he was helping the universe so the only
way I see him actually wanting to rule
the universe itself is if he feels like
things are in chaos and he feels like
only he can bring that order like the
way that a psychopath or some evil
dictator would feel like he's helping
everyone by showing them how they're
supposed to live so you guys let me know
what you think about this I'm 50/50 on
it like the Russos even actually talked
about some of the toy leaks that have
happened there like be careful because
some of the toy leaks are based on early
concepts that never made it into the
final cut of the film so there's gonna
be a whole lot of stuff that's released
for Avengers endgame and pictures behind
the scenes stuff that doesn't wind up
making it into the theatrical cut of the
film
remember towards the end of last year
when they revealed all those deleted
concepts and deleted scenes from earlier
versions of infinity war like spider-man
in the red looking authentic comic book
iron spider suit there was another
version of it where they gave him a
black costume there was an alternate
ending that they had where all the
Avengers were fighting Thanos in a very
different type of scene in Wakanda so if
you thought that it was a lot of bonus
content and just like extra stuff that
didn't make it into infinity war there's
gonna be even more of that stuff for
Avengers end game so what'll probably
happen is is later this year when they
released the blu-ray for Avengers end
game we'll find out what all that stuff
is so of course I'll do
videos for when it gets here but just
remember that a lot of that stuff you
don't find out about till months and
months after the movie comes out but
like I said what'll probably happen is
is because Captain Marvel is coming out
in less than a month is when that drops
in theaters that's when our next
Avengers endgame trailer is gonna drop
we'll get more footage of Iron Man in
outer space with nebula very small
chance they release some endgame footage
with Captain Marvel in it but I'm
expecting them to hold that until the
last possible minute if at all but she's
a pretty big character during endgame so
it feels like they would at least put
her in one of the trailers even if they
wait till like the last possible minute
to do it the other really big news you
guys may have seen this morning people
freaking out about was they announced
four brand-new adult animation Marvel TV
series that are gonna be going to Hulu
Disney also confirmed that that's where
they're putting all their r-rated
content and it'll all make sense in a
second when I explain what these TV
shows are and what they're doing with
them so they're for TV shows that are
set in the same universe they're all
going to cross over in a separate series
defender style that they're doing the
Marvel Netflix thing with four different
animated characters or really it's five
characters so what it is is it's Howard
the Duck TV show from Kevin Smith a
MODOK TV show from Patton Oswalt a hit
monkey TV show then the TV show about
Tigre and Dazzler because I guess they
wanted some female characters on their
big crossover team-up show after each of
their first seasons air defender style
they'll team up in a show called get it
the offenders so it's basically Disney
and Marvel doing a super raunchy super
offensive super comic book animated
version of the defenders but it's gonna
be on Hulu and that also probably means
because that's basically where all their
r-rated content is going is that
eventually that adult animation Deadpool
of TV show that we heard about last year
that Donald Glover was supposed to be
making will eventually go to Hulu but
they haven't said anything about that
recently until Marvel pulled the project
back but it just confirmation that
that's where all like the really adult
stuff is gonna go with in Disney's
content sphere because all the stuff
that's going to the Disney Plus
streaming service is meant to be pg-13
at most but when they start dropping
trailers fertile of course I'll do
videos maybe they'll have some trailers
at Comic Con later this summer but let
me know in the comments they do more
adult animation Marvel series on Hulu
which characters do you want to get TV
shows
everybody's been ripping apart Will
Smith in the blue Jeannie this morning
so let me know if you want me to do a
reaction video for Aladdin but there's a
whole bunch of other stuff that I'll try
to get to this morning Game of Thrones
that's coming up post all your video
requests in the comments below click
here for my brand new Avengers endgame
trailer video and click here for my
brand-new Game of Thrones season 8
preview video thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight
[Music]